[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
among the novelties several new
generation electric cars
even the producers who had always
snubbed the sector launch into what
appears to be the new business
this is kira nero
even before it was launched on the
market in norway a paradise for electric
cars it had 5 000 reservations
mercedes eqc a compact suv a premium
category very technological marking the
presence of the german brand on the
market
it's not a fashion or a trend you know
sometimes a market decides on its own to
move towards the electric industry
when people are ready to buy cars
the future of mobility is electric
now it's one percent of the global
market meaning that electric will not
become important until it reaches 10
percent
[Music]
from the futuristic visions of an
electric future let us return to the
present in tecino
657 electric cars are registered out of
227 000
that is 0.2 of the fleet
a very poor percentage that reflects the
national situation
[Music]
in the mandarin area we are facing the
problem of pollution
so we really decided to buy the electric
car because it doesn't pollute our
conscience is clear especially if i
think of my son
currently in switzerland there are no
incentives enticino who drives an
electric car is often an idealist who
doesn't want to pollute in the canton
caught in the grips of traffic and which
is always lagging behind in swiss air
quality statistics
however the tristanese council of state
in compliance with the air
rehabilitation plan would like to
introduce subsidies to promote the
spread of zero emission cars
the message will be discussed shortly in
parliament
switching to an electric car what are
its consequences
we met some drivers who have already
made the choice
with their son antonio they have two
cars both electric one is actually
little more than a motorcycle but with
this performance has convinced the riva
family to dispose of the petrol car
which consumed too much with a quick
internet search they found a great
occasion for a car in german-speaking
switzerland
[Music]
we paid for it half price summing up
however at the end that extra price you
pay to buy it is compensated by a lot of
lower costs
the insurance the license plates the
petrol itself parking space and above
all also consumption and maintenance
to bring home the second hand bmw i3 the
river family experiences the famous
autonomy panic because the car at least
on paper can circulate for about 200
kilometers before being recharged but
the way back is longer however they
decided to leave still in experience
they arrive at a non-functioning column
at the next they fail to recharge until
they attach themselves to a hotel outlet
after a two hour stop the battery
indicates 20 kilometers of autonomy and
so they face the gutter tunnel
i kept looking at how many kilometers
were left to the exit of the tunnel
and how many kilometers of autonomy we
still had
and the two more were less equated
we went to energy saving turn off air
conditioning
the car behind us continued to flash his
headlights
he was a bit agitated because of people
driving 60 kilometers per hour in the
gutter there is a lot anyway
once we got halfway where it starts
descending we magically went from six
kilometers that we had left of autonomy
to 18.
by releasing the accelerator pedal or
braking energy is recovered and today
the riva family adopts all the solutions
to recharge from home solutions less
practical but at no cost they have a
photovoltaic system on the roof to
public columns crossing the border is no
longer a problem
today they go to veris where their sun
trains in mini rugby
for a long trip there are online
calculators that by setting the various
parameters air temperature distance and
so on they calculate for you if you
travel at 40 kilometers per hour on
average you can do this distance if you
travel at 80 clearly you do a little
less
it is a different way of traveling
earlier we used to start from a point a
to point b now we can enjoy the journey
more because we may stop in a place that
we didn't know recharge the car take a
walk things
[Music]
ana maria who used to frequently refill
her car at the public column in chiesel
near the office when it would still be
done for free paying only an annual
subscription of 100 friends does not bat
an eye today having to pay both recharge
and stop
it was my 65th birthday that gave me the
right to retirement and so it became
almost a symbolic matter
65 years retirement electric car
i wanted a car that could support me in
my wishes going around maybe
envelope to take photographs but with
something that didn't affect the
environment
[Music]
and then after putting the solar panels
thinking to have a sort of petrol pump
on the roof also that was a
something that fits perfectly
paul nicole bought a nissan leaf last
december
the world's best-selling electric car
it's the latest model which is not yet
on the market
the car will be delivered six months
later
the seller promises him about 380
kilometers of autonomy
it seemed to me something that was quite
guaranteed by the manufacturer by the
seller despite the fact that this car
was unknown covered in a cloud of
mystery because it was not yet possible
to touch it or try it and one just had
to trust words
the autonomy of an electric car depends
on many factors the speed the use of air
conditioning or heating frequent
accelerations and going uphill use up
energy diminishing the kilometers that
can be covered by quite a lot
paul is aware of it
but he almost immediately experiences a
bitter disappointment
[Music]
i went to melbourne and back 196
kilometers
and i arrived home being afraid of
staying on the street with 10 percent
autonomy
[Music]
i wrote to nissan saying that
i don't want to say scams because maybe
it's too big a word for this case but
it's not truthful information
it's information that goes against the
interest of a consumer
in the letter to nissan paul writes
over the month have partially corrected
your parameters but for those like me
who purchased in 2017
nissan replies
the data in our brochure is measured in
a laboratory naturally they cannot be
compared with those provided by the
consumer
the manufacturer's response does not
satisfy our driver at all but how could
this happen
the data of consumption and therefore of
autonomy never correspond
those declared to those that the
consumer experiences every day
because the laws were written in a way
that favored the builders in all
conceivable ways
now the laws have changed since
september of this year regulations have
been introduced trying to bring what has
been declared closer to the reality
but there will always be a gap and this
applies to both normal cars and electric
cars
currently according to the new standards
nissan declares 389 kilometers of
autonomy in the urban cycle and 270 in
the combined cycle that is if you are
also driving outside the city
the tcs which tested the car believes
that the autonomy that can actually be
reached in the city traffic is an
average of 234 kilometers while quoting
autonomy at the speed of 120 kilometer
literally precipitates
in our small survey half of the electro
drivers turn to the second hand market
attorney garbani is instead one of those
who opted for a new car
an opel and vera e
it is true they do cost a little more
but i install solar panels on my roof i
practically travel free and do not
pollute and in these six months i drove
more than ten thousand kilometers i have
used public chargers for a maximum of 20
francs
for me it's rare to recharge in the same
columns today is an exception because i
didn't have time to recharge it and then
i'll have to leave it there and go back
to the office
here we are
it doesn't work this time either it does
not read the card
marco garbani three months ago had
pointed out that the emoti column of
sarango near his office wasn't working
and verified that the problem was not
linked to his card
today the situation repeats the lawyer
calls the hotline again
they'll pay the recharge possibly it's
an error in the chip
he advised me to use the mobile phone
app but i am no longer part of the
electric generation
i try to avoid downloading apps on my
mobile phone i prefer holding things in
my hand like the card instead of playing
with a mobile phone
when i have to make a journey beyond the
autonomy of my small electric car i look
at one of the available apps that tell
me where the columns are along my route
these are the columns that i find in
zurich
i can also book it in many cases so i
have the guarantee that it is free when
i arrive and then along the way there
are all the other ones i can choose
i bought a pizzan which is a small
four-seater electric car with a quite
limited autonomy
[Music]
i use it as a second car meaning i use
it to drive around town to make short
trips and above all i can take it to the
front of the house when i have shopping
bags it's very comfortable
a computer journalist and owner of a
petrol motor opal mocha six months ago
bought a second-hand electric car for 12
000 francs and spent 760 francs on a
small wall box a home charge device
a full charge of an electric car which
is about 100 kilometers of autonomy cost
me less than three francs when i charge
at night at home
if on the other hand i have to drive 100
kilometers on my petrol car the concrete
accounts tells me that my consumption is
around 11 francs
in these months i have saved about 300
francs of energy only
energy
the comparison here is between small
electric and medium petrol cars
but in general is the electrician
convenient or not
it is difficult to talk about electric
cars at switzerland in terms of pure
savings that is not the goal to look for
but you do save it depends on which car
we are comparing it to
the tcs has made a comparison between
cars of the same category
electric cars when purchased are more
expensive than heat engine cars
a fact that reoccurs in all categories
city cars compact high-end cars which
however are slightly more expensive
it is true that electric cars and tocino
pays a lower circulation tax and the
energy to recharge them costs two-thirds
less than fossil fuel but it is
advisable to install a home wall box
that will also require the intervention
of an electrician
it is possible to imagine a draw in
kilometers in these conditions
according to tcs calculations with an
electric city car it would be necessary
to cover the mileage with a mid-range
car the draw is reached after about 180
000 kilometers while high-end electric
cars or the same performance are
considerably more competitive after 88
000 kilometers savings already amount to
over 7000 francs
[Music]
gather once a month
all happy owners of a high-end super
technological car which can be quickly
recharged in this service station 20
minutes to restore 50 of the battery
i come from coratino and i am a retired
teacher bidono employee lugano
telecommunications ligorneto technician
san bernardino taxi driver gudo
videomaker
how many teslas are there in tecino
about 80 actually there are almost 300
teslas in tesino
those who buy tesla make a non-economic
choice
more ecologically driven or an image
choice for many people
tesla boasts an extensive network of
unlimited free chargers for those who
bought the car by mid-september of this
year
and there are those who took advantage
of it for an exciting journey
i went to the north cape from nicholetto
to the north cape
[Music]
a charger wasn't working and they had to
go to a hotel and they charged me for
five euros a thousand kilometers at a
cost of five francs
[Music]
at the paris motor show there was also
the latest tesla model 3 smaller than
the previous ones which has already
received hundreds of thousands of
bookings from all over the world
the first deliveries are scheduled in
europe next year the announced price for
these base model in the united states is
35 000
or about 35 000 francs competitive with
mid-range cars
the most prestigious car manufacturers
sensing the business it is appropriate
to say
are heating the engines
we will introduce 10 vehicles by 2022
they are all going to be full electric
vehicles this is the first of the
mercedes so there will be six more for
the eq series so we have a broad
strategy
at delmer we have clearly decided that
electric mobility will be one of the
pillars of the future
we have not yet announced the price for
this car i think it will be very
competitive even compared to cars with
combustion engines
without forgetting that from 2020 the
smart the small car born 20 years ago
will be only electric
at the show
we also enjoy a futuristic and fun
prototype
i think it's a good idea i think it's a
good idea driving an electric smart in
the city they are very practical driving
in a city without co2 emissions makes
perfect sense
after the enthusiasm of the mercedes
manager the disenchanted point of view
of the director of the most prestigious
italian automotive magazine
the car is facing an epochal paradigm
shift this paradigm shift would not have
started if the diesel gate had not
arrived in september three years ago
suddenly we realized a whole series of
flaws and problems that this industry
has always had as for example the fact
that the controllers were also those
undergoing control at the same time
it was a turning point those who have
had the money to face a paradigm shift
are doing it and are doing so by turning
to electric
and there will be a reason why many
novelties presented at the show fall
into the premium category which means
expensive
we see the audi e-tron we see the
mercedes we see the tesla there are cars
that will cost from 80 000 to 100 000
euros up cars that are cheap and offers
high autonomy can be counted in the
fingers of one hand for example the audi
e-tron has a 700 kilogram battery
it is half the weight of a normal car at
a time when you will have more powerful
more capable and smaller batteries at
that point these batteries can be used
on smaller therefore cheaper cars
right now according to how things are
incentives are fundamental the electric
is currently a business backed by the
community's money
[Music]
already believed in electric cars 20
years ago when the pilot project of the
confederation was launched in manchester
for the promotion of eel
which then extended to the entire canton
and which relied on public money and
private sponsorships the incentives
reached half the value of the car
22 000 francs were more or less the
cause of the car at that time and with
the incentives in the end i paid 11 000
francs the problem of battery rental
still remained because the batteries
were not sold with the vehicle and was
200 francs a month
there was still another problem a matter
of how to recharge a car
[Music]
the column here
is a very first generation
in the year 2000 almost no one had an
electric car
everyone wanted to try it and see how it
worked but when it was said that the
maximum range was 80 kilometers and
there are recharging problems the
average user was immediately discouraged
we instead choose to go for a ride it
looks like a toy car
i turn on the vehicle by turning the key
when it does click i am ready to go
if i want to back up i have this button
i want to go forward it's the same
button
there is the break
as there was on cars ones heating and
that's
[Music]
in 2015 the vel project comes to an end
because in a referendum people of tisino
reject the idea of financing new
eco-incentives with the increase overall
tax
a rejection that did not stop damiano as
he also owns the penultimate model of
the nissan leaf
what bothers him most is that the rates
for public charges have recently
increased
a recharge here can cost me seven or
eight francs at home i could easily pay
a quarter of this amount
so what you would like is a little lower
rates
exactly above all that of parking fees
outside the centers because they don't
make sense to me since the parking lots
outside the centers as also happen here
are free or partially free i don't see
why i charge for parking when we already
pay rather expensive costs per kilowatt
hour of electricity
[Music]
one of the very few towns that has
already established incentives for the
purchase of electric cars as of this
year residents can receive grants up to
three thousand francs
unfortunately laurent has already bought
his e-golf but he doesn't feel cheated
i bought the car at the wrong time but
in my opinion the trend will always be
this
this cannot go on the traffic is
increasing more and more we are
polluting more and more the pollution
values increase and one must start to
think about a solution
don't you feel a little drop in the
sieve
absolutely yes but many small drops can
change something
[Music]
this one too does not read the card
i was told to start it with the app the
app clearly worked with a mobile phone
if the telephone network does not
connect we are unable to start charging
at the feet of the gutter pass ramp we
meet franco buldo
manager of entering owner of the
manufacturing emoji columns
after the second case we want to
understand what the failures were due to
the problems were related to a rather
insignificant cable that connected a
card reader and which presented a false
contact
so a problem also difficult to find out
because sometimes it worked and
sometimes it didn't
however i assure you that the cable in
question has been replaced and the
columns are now fully functioning
manager who groups the 10 main
electricity distribution companies of
the canton these are events that can
happen
especially when managing the largest
public access charging network in tocino
at the moment we have about 80
recharging stations in the chino
territory most of them are normal
recharging columns and here right behind
me we have a fast charging column which
is currently the only one integrated in
the emoji network
the normal columns recharge up to 100
kilometers of real autonomy for each
hour of recharge the quick column
recharges a little more in less than
half an hour to the drivers who
criticized a high rise in fees the
manager of interi answered this way
the confederation has decided to lead
the initiative to private individuals
not to subsidize neither the recharging
columns nor the purchase of the vehicles
so being the columns market's privately
owned market nobody can afford to do
on the one charity the confederation
does not allocate subsidies on the other
hand that the ticinos tried instead to
plan new incentives 2.5 million francs
of the purchase of electric cars and
half a million to encourage the
installation of charging stations at
home and the workplace a contradiction
[Music]
the confederation announces support for
electric mobility giving up however the
provision of direct contributions the
canton is in a complementary position to
start this process of replacing the cars
to compensate at least a little
the difference in purchase price for the
potentially interested users
a modest measure that will finance a
thousand cars at most
the state will pay 2 000 francs if the
car manufacturer will grant as much
it is illusory to think that this
intervention could really contribute to
reduce air pollution caused by traffic
if this incentive is successful it can
be repeated later on
if market conditions were to required
it also wants to be in particular the
attempt to bring new users hopefully the
younger people closer to the electric
vehicle
clearly if we limit to those thousand
cars then the effect on air quality is
negligible
and if this measure will be approved
what resources will there be from
manufacturers
if a government decides to do something
that is to increase the amount of
electric vehicles it is a good idea as a
brand we believe we must produce cars
that customers buy simply because they
are beautiful cars but if you go in this
direction local retailers will decide
what to do
they say three people out of six we met
have photovoltaic systems the same
number bought a second hand electric car
only one regretted the choice a little
but will not sell it
everyone except one still use a
traditional car for long journeys or
holidays
a picture in which the glue represents
the ecological spirit will the
government with its maneuver intercept
other drivers now that new interesting
models are starting to be available
pets are open
[Music]